what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and yesterday we were hit with some
insane news news that is forever going
to change DC as we know it the news that
Henry Cavill is officially done as
Superman yesterday on Instagram Henry
Cavill announced that he met with James
Gunn and Peter Safran and DC and he has
done a Superman not because he wanted to
be done as Superman but because James
Gunn and Peter Safran have other plans
for the DCU including a new Superman
movie that is actually going to be
revealed soon according to James Gunn
but will not involve Henry Cavill and of
course we're going to be talking about
that in this video and talking about the
entire future of DC what does this mean
now that Henry Cavill is out is Jason
Momoa safe is gal gadosafe who is
staying who is leaving heck we don't
even know if the rock is safe as Black
Adam right now in the DCU one thing is
very clear James Gunn and Peter Safran
have a vision and it seems like they
have decided what is best for the DCU
moving forward and nothing's really
going to get in their way including
someone as iconic as Henry Cavill
Superman who the fans truly do love and
feel like he was done kind of dirty with
this but what is really happening over
at DC right now like I mentioned it's
very clear right now that James Gunn and
Peter Safran have an idea a vision of
what the DCU should be and they have
created a plan for their movies coming
up their TV shows coming up their games
coming up because James Gunn said it's
all connecting even video games some of
the video games are going to connect and
James Gunn and Peter saffron recently
took a little retreat they spent some
time over in Colorado simply doing
nothing but writing what they call the
DC Bible basically what they did was
come up with how everything is going to
connect in their universe and actually
they are submitting all of their plans
to Warner Brothers Discovery very very
soon and considering the fact that Henry
Cavill met with James Gunn and Peter
Safran and that was the end of it it
looks like they have everything complete
it looks like they have their full
vision ready to go so last night after
Henry Cavill posted his statement on
Instagram James Gunn took to Twitter and
announced a couple of things himself now
real quick if you didn't hear about
Henry Cavill last night or you didn't
read the post this is what it says I
have just had a meeting with James Gunn
and Peter Safran and it's sad news
everyone I will after all not be
returning as Superman after being told
by the studio to announce my return back
in October prior to their hire this news
isn't the easiest but that's life The
Changing of the Guard is something that
happens I respect that James and Peter
have a universe to build I wish them and
all involved with the new universe the
best of luck in the happiest of Fortunes
for those who have been on my side
through the years we can mourn for a bit
but then we must remember Superman is
still around everything he stands for
still exists and the examples he sets
for us are still there my turn to where
the cape has passed but what Superman
stands for never will it's been a fun
ride with you all onwards and upwards
it's extremely sad it really is but
Henry Cavill responded to this perfectly
I think with true class but besides
Henry Cavill no longer being Superman
here's what stands out to me and what he
said and I think it's pretty important
he says that James and Peter have a
universe to build then he says I wish
them and all involved with the new
universe the best of luck this pretty
much means that James Gunn and Peter
Safran are kind of resetting everything
we thought that it might be sort of a
soft reboot but now that Henry Cavill is
out of Superman it's looking like it's
going to be an extremely hard reboot and
a report came out by The Hollywood
Reporter stating that gal gadot's Wonder
Woman 3 has been scrapped and Patty
Jenkins came out and said thank you for
all the time and all the love that we've
given Wonder Woman in her movies so it's
looking like Gal Gadot is done as well
James Gunn and Peter saffron have a
completely new DC slate ready to go that
they're going to reveal to us relatively
soon and it looks like it's not going to
involve any of the old characters so for
those who were hoping that Zack Snyder's
Justice League would be kind of given a
Redemption Arc here it doesn't look like
it at all in fact I'm pretty sure one of
James guns and Peter safran's priorities
was to kind of move away from that after
the news that Henry Cavill was done as
Superman was announced yesterday this is
what James Gunn said on Twitter Peter
and I have a DC slate ready to go which
we couldn't be more over the moon about
we'll be able to share some exciting
information about our first projects at
the beginning of the new year among
those on the Slate is Superman in the
initial stages our story will be
focusing on an earlier part of
Superman's life so the character will
not be played by Henry Cavill but we
just had a great meeting with Henry and
we're big fans and we talked about a
number of exciting possibilities to work
together in the future this is big news
right here and I'll come back to this in
just a second somebody asked James Gunn
about the Superman movie stating that
it's being a part of the Slate so they
assume it's a movie in which James Gunn
replied yes so this new Superman Project
is going to be a movie he then stated
that he is writing the script for the
new Superman movie and has been for a
while but he doesn't know who is
directing it yet he also mentioned
something kind of exciting one user
asked him if Ben afflecked could direct
and he replied with met with Ben
yesterday precisely because he wants to
direct and we want him to direct we just
have to find the right project that
implies that Ben Affleck's Batman is
most likely done as well however what
James Gunn said is very interesting when
he said they had a great meeting with
Henry and their big fans and they talked
about a number of exciting possibilities
to work together in the future so as I
mentioned James Gunn clearly has a very
clear path that he wants to take the DCU
down and considering the fact that
they're doing a new Superman movie
that's going to focus on the earlier
parts of Superman's life as in when he
is younger that implies that the DCU
really is resetting and they're starting
over and they're going to start when
these characters are younger but that
doesn't mean that when these characters
eventually grow up we could see older
versions of them played by some of the
original actors perhaps there's a
Superman movie that said in the future
after this one that's going to come out
and Henry Cavill could return to play
Superman it kind of sounds like that is
one of the possibilities that James Gunn
is talking about of ways to work
together in the future with Henry Cavill
plus not to mention it does seem like DC
might explore the Multiverse and if they
start from scratch and set it up the
right way it can be done in a very very
excellent way and that opens it up for
all of these original characters to
return Gal Gadot Ben Affleck Jason Momoa
and of course Henry Cavill now Aquaman 2
is still set to come out and so is
Shazam 2. however their Futures are kind
of unknown right now in fact it looks
like and is very very hinted that Jason
Momoa might actually be playing Lobo in
fact James Gunn himself kind of hinted
at this and Jason Momoa honestly would
make a perfect Lobo and that probably
means that he is done as Aquaman as well
so we no longer have Henry Cavill as
Superman Gal Gadot looks like she is
done as Wonder Woman and Jason Momoa
might be done as Aquaman and I don't
think Ben Affleck just coming back as
Batman and given everything that has
happened into Ezra Miller I'm pretty
sure Ezra's done as well so it truly
does seem like they are scrapping the
entire old DC Universe and they're going
to be completely starting a new one and
the question is is this good or bad fans
are reacting in very very different ways
to this news some really don't like
James Gunn right now because they loved
Henry Cavill as Superman some don't like
him because they wanted the Snyder verse
restored but some actually see that this
could be a very very good thing and I
personally think that it could be a very
very good thing I am sad to see all of
these old characters go and the actors
that played them I think they were all
fantastic however DC has been in a rut
and their plan has been all over the
place they've been messy and what they
really need is some true Direction and
it seems like that's what James Gunn and
Peter saffron have it seems like they
know what the DCU needs and they're
really not going to let anything get in
the way of them making it great
including getting rid of some very
beloved actors and characters but they
have a vision and they're going for it
and I'm really excited to see what
happens and right now I think this is
kind of make or break for the DCU if
James Gunn and Peter saffron don't pull
this off and DC doesn't bounce back I
think a lot of people are probably going
to be done with DC of course there will
always be fans and there's always going
to be another chance but right now
people are even petitioning for Warner
Brothers to keep Henry Cavill and fire
James Gunn so fans are really divided
right now and I think if this fails it's
going to be really really bad for DC but
Peter Safran and James Gunn both have
really good track records when it comes
to movies James Gunn has been very
successful with the Guardians of the
Galaxy franchise directing Guardians of
the Galaxy one through three and the
Christmas holiday special and of course
he brought us the suicide squad the
newer one and The Peacemaker series both
of which were fantastic Peter Safran has
also worked on some great DC projects
and other movie projects as well that
have been really good and they're both
fans they're both fans of DC so they
don't want anything to screw up they
don't want to ruin the DCU they want to
restore it they want to revive it they
want to make DC great and they have a
plan they have their Full Slate planned
out which means they most likely are
doing phases Now The Rock has teased
that Black Adam was the first movie of
phase one however the rock also said
Henry Cavill was back and some other
things and Peter saffron and James Gunn
came in and basically negated what he
said he said all of those things before
they were put in charge so unfortunately
we don't really know if they're going to
be doing phases but since James Gunn
used the word slate it does seem like
they are which is good because we need
that structure for DC that is one thing
that DC has lacked structure and a clear
direction of where they're going to go
instead of being all over the place like
we were before everybody was pretty
confused about what was really happening
with DC and the DC EU before but it
seems like James and Peter have a very
clear vision of what they're going to be
going for so hopefully this is a brand
new start for DC hopefully fans can give
these new actors and characters a chance
and hopefully the franchise is about to
make a very very good comeback but hey
let us know what you you think about
this in the comments down below are you
happy are you sad are you looking
forward to the future let us know all
your thoughts down below also don't
forget to like the video and subscribe
to stay up to date with all DC news for
live updates you can follow us on
Instagram and Twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching wolf
wolf